she's the original it girl of the 90s
the definition of hair goals one of the
most iconic characters in the history of
sitcoms she is the timelessly talented
and beautiful Jennifer Aniston we all
know her we all love her and we all
desperately want to know her secret to
not aging a day since her TV debut but
considering she has a self-proclaimed
obsession with all things Wellness I
think it's high time we take a deep dive
into everything Jen Aniston eats in a
day hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
I'll be eating like actress Jennifer
Aniston but you know switching things up
because obviously my needs are unique so
I'm just gonna be using her alleged
meals as a template for teaching gent
nutrition and inspiring what I decide to
make for me that works for my body also
a reminder that this alleged diet was
compiled from primary and secondary
sources so I really can't speak to its
legitimacy or accuracy and as a reminder
this is just what I ate on a random day
and it's not meant to be copied or
recommended as how you should eat always
speak to a registered dietitian about
your unique needs and don't forget to
hit that subscribe button if you are not
already subscribed and follow me on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's kitchen
before I go too far let's chat about
today's sponsor block blast so block
blast is a really fun block and brain
puzzle game that combines creativity
with the classics I don't know about you
guys but at the end of my work day after
the kids go down on I'm usually just
like dying to zone out and this is a
really easy game to get started on and
it's suitable for all ages but it does
take a lot of practice and attempts to
completely Master it hence why it's so
insanely addictive but if you're into
block games you're going to love block
blast you basically drag and drop blocks
onto the board to fill a row or column
to complete elimination and when you
clear a bunch of rows you earn extra
points when my five-year-old sees me
playing he's begging me to let him play
too admittedly he has been dragging down
my score total but I guess motherhood is
a selfless job so if you guys want to
try a block blast yourself you can
download it on Google Play or at the
Apple Store and check out the link in my
description to learn more alright Abby
I'm hungry get at me all right the 90s
kid in me is like pretty excited about
this let's talk about Jennifer Jennifer
Jen I feel like she's like a gen Vibe so
let's go with that alright Accord
according to Jen I don't do coffee first
up I do a juice first up and then coffee
about a half hour later after meditation
she usually will hold off on her morning
coffee and have celery juice first
then meditate and then do coffee about
like a half hour later you guys know me
I'm usually like a coffee first then
function kind of gal uh but I feel like
we could double fist it and have them at
the same time and not be in a terrible
mood ugh looks like sludge water
oh nope
that's not happening let's talk about
coffee okay so according to sources Jen
typically takes her coffee with a splash
of almond milk Stevia cinnamon and vital
proteins collagen powder which she has
been like a long-term Ambassador for
okay well any coffee is good coffee so
while I whip this up Abby can you tell
us a little bit more about collagen
supplements sure thing Abby so collagen
protein is essential for the structural
Integrity of not only our skin but also
our bones muscle hair and tendons as we
age the production of collagen naturally
declines resulting in the appearance of
fine lines and wrinkles considering that
Jen Anderson has seemingly not aged a
day over like the past 20 years or more
it's totally understandable that a lot
of folks myself included want to copy
her beauty regimen but when it comes to
collagen and skin Health a recent
meta-analysis found that it did in
improve skin quality after three months
of supplementation however these
findings were heavily criticized in the
media the million dollar question here
is whether or not there's something
unique in collagen powder that improves
skin elasticity or if we can get that
same benefit from consuming more quality
protein since collagen can be
synthesized in-house using amino acids
from protein-rich Foods plus vitamin C
the closest we come in a study to
comparing collagen to protein was done
in a hospital where they gave one
elderly group collagen but then they
lowered the rest of their protein intake
to match that of the general protein
diet group it would have been a lot more
useful to increase the protein since
generally that is what a supplement does
especially when they only ended up with
around 1.1 grams of protein per kilogram
which really isn't that high for this
demographic it's actually below what's
recommended for elderly folk that said
the collagen group did see improvements
in skin elasticity and hydration so this
is definitely super promising but it is
just one small study and a study using
pretty low protein standards in an
elderly population that doesn't
necessarily apply to young healthy
people who are getting in a lot more
protein in their day now the other
promising
is related to what makes collagen
protein unique so collagen is rich in
hydroxyproline Proline and glycine which
research suggests are absorbed as
dipeptides rather than being broken into
individual amino acids so Proline
hydroxyproline is specifically the
dipeptide most important for signaling
skin cell proliferation and hyaluronic
acid synthesis which is an important
component of skin elasticity so it does
seem very plausible that the dipeptide
skin signaling gives collagen a bit of
an edge over other protein but here's
where the uncertainty lies with enough
protein the body can synthesize
dipeptides like Proline hydroxyproline
so again would getting more General
protein just do the same thing we don't
really know we also don't have any
research looking at protein intake
levels more in line with young healthy
people who are already used to
supplementing with protein powders if
you're consuming closer to 1.3 to 1.4
gram grams of protein per kilogram of
body weight and you're synthesizing your
own dipeptides does collagen really
offer a significant Edge again not
really sure so yeah there is a reason
why this is such a Hot Topic right now
and I'm really looking forward to
hopefully having a definitive answer one
day soon all right scuba collagen
let's whisk that in
I knew that was going to happen
okay good enough a little almond milk
it's just a splash allegedly
I'm gonna go for a little bit extra
splash
stevia
I'm already hating this
and cinnamon
this looks interesting
not how I usually like my coffee but
it's better than the celery juice so
I'll take it okay so while I'm nursing
this Abby can you tell us a little bit
about whether or not it's a concern that
I'm drinking my coffee first okay so
there is some concern in the Wellness
Community around drinking coffee first
thing in the morning on an empty stomach
as it may potentially increase our
stress hormone cortisol which is also
naturally highest in the morning and
while it is technically true that
caffeine does appear to heightened
cortisol levels it's important to note
that these effects are transient in
other words any effect that caffeine has
on cortisol levels seems to diminish
with regular caffeine consumption we
also have no evidence that consuming
coffee on an empty stomach would make
this effect dramatically more pronounced
though it can sometimes be harder on
people's guts so there's that okay so
that's why I had a little bit of a
do-over and we're doing a latte here
folks because a that's what I like and
also I like that I'm getting a little
bit of carbs fat and protein to buffer
the effects of the caffeine on my gut
okay so your girl is hungry as usual
let's see what Jen usually has for some
food for breakfast that's just don't eat
breakfast I just have juice like a green
juice in the coffee it doesn't count
turns out I don't think it's it's I
noticed a big difference just literally
going that 14 hours right 16 sorry 16
hours without salt without food I'm
pretty sure the coffee and the juice do
count
um Abby did these break a fast yeah
that's both in short anything with
calories will break a fast and that
includes juice and coffee with any kind
of sugar milk or cream inside it and
considering Jen takes her coffee with
milk and collagen both of which contain
carbs and protein she's diminishing any
of the insulin suppressing and autophagy
benefits of fasting this isn't even
technically what they would call like a
dirty fast which is a wellness culture
way of saying cutting calories because
the coffee and Juice combo likely yields
more than the allow out 100 calories
spoiler alert all of this is
the only benefit of this pseudo 16 hour
fast is weight management because you're
just basically skipping a meal and a 16
hour fast is pretty aggressive for most
women because the reproductive system is
very sensitive to energy imbalances and
if intermittent fasting means eating
less calories overall it can put you in
a chronic state of low energy available
for hormone regulation yeah I'm not
going to be attempting that I am still
trying to regulate my cycle post
breastfeeding and my doctor said
intermittent fasting is a big No-No but
thankfully before this whole
pseudo-intermittent fasting phase Jen
was a breakfast eater so let's refer
back to Circa 2016 to see what she ate
for breakfast so according to L for
breakfast Jen would usually have either
avocado and eggs or oatmeal with egg
whites whipped in for some extra protein
okay I'm loving the variety here so lots
to choose from it's cold outside so I
feel like it's an oatmeal day and the
egg white hack is something that I do
all the time you guys know that as a
staple Abby's Kitchen Recipe so let's go
with that but let's do it up into a
hunger crushing combo to make it a
little more satiating let's make
breakfast all right so first things
first we're going to separate some eggs
get the egg whites
it's dangerous there is a technique and
I'm not following it
I accidentally put one of the yolks into
my garbage pile so that one would just
leave to die
let's wash our hands
all right first things first let's cook
some oats
[Music]
milky milk you can also use water
good
pinch of salt essential
oh I like some cinnamon where are you
cinnamon
Punker all right and let's just give
that a good stir
okay while that's gonna simmer
let's work on our eggs got my egg whites
whip those up
probably should have used a bigger bowl
get your arm workout in for the day
can you add the song Beat It please
we love a food pun
I'm gonna find a use for these don't you
worry it's looking good smells good
all right get those whipped eggs
and we're going to
whip them in
you got to move them quick so they don't
scramble
I'm gonna move this aside while I got my
banana ready squish a nice ripe banana
because it's going to add lots of
natural sweetness
put on let her sit for like four minutes
and we played her up
she fluffy
huge huge bowl of fluffy protein oats
here looks so good
all right let's
slice the rest of this banana
I hate those little stringy things those
have to go that is just like
all right
some blueberries
I've got like a nice selection
of fruit here
I have freeze-dried strawberries which
I'm like currently obsessed with and
that's like a nice crunch Factor plus a
ton of flavor we need a little peanut
butter for some healthy fats
and all up
oh yeah
and you know
if you know you know
that looks so good
I mean
perfection
actually
one last thing I feel like I could use
mini chocolate chips because today is
Friday when I'm filming this and I just
feel like some chocolate in my life all
right let's recap folks we have protein
in all of those egg whites plus of
course some nut butter and the hemp
seeds which also supplies some delicious
healthy fats and we have tons of carbs
from the oats plus all the berries on
top and a little chocolate for good
measure this is one of my favorite
recipes so I'm super glad that Jen and I
are on the same wavelength
hmm
[Music]
always ahead okay so now that I'm
caffeinated and motivated and have some
fuel in the tank it's time for a
Jennifer Aniston inspired workout so
other than her love of yoga Jen swears
by a combination of Pilates and cardio
she allegedly told in style that one of
her go-to cardio workouts is the 15 15
method where she does 15 minutes of
spinning 15 minutes of elliptical and 15
minutes of running I don't have an
elliptical so I'm gonna do 50 minutes of
spinning 15 of running and 15 of some
kind of like Pilates style workouts
let's do it
la la la la la la la la
[Music]
[Applause]
la la la la la
la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
all right since we got a little sweat
sesh in let's talk some post-workout
fuel uh according to Jennifer her go-to
protein shake is a combination of
bananas cherries blackberries greens
powder more collagen cacao powder Stevia
drops and chocolate almond milk I think
chocolate cherries are like a Heavenly
combination so I'm genuinely excited
about this one but do we really need the
powdered greens Abby probably not I also
have a whole video dedicated to Greens
powders which you can check out right
here but in short greens powders don't
do anything miraculous for your health
that natural whole fruits and vegetables
don't already do I like to think of them
more as like a powdered multivitamin
they'll never replace whole veg because
they lack beneficial fibers and if
you're already getting a variety of
produce in your day they're probably
largely obsolete well that's good
because I really didn't want to spend
another 50 on an extra supplement so I'm
just going to use some frozen kale AKA
actual whole greens to get my fix a
handful of greens
[Applause]
got some frozen berry mix
cherries blackberries and blueberries
I love that
all right banana
little cocoa cacao Coke cow cacao
that's a lot
just a little bit I don't like things
too chocolatey and speaking of
chocolatey I'm actually going to add
some chocolate protein powder because
I've got the collagen I'm gonna add that
too but collagen protein is not really
like a complete protein so it's not
ideal as like a post-workout protein so
we can do a combo here a little collagen
to make Jen happy and a little bit of
chocolate whey isolate
there you go mix these she doesn't add
peanut butter or any kind of like
healthy fats in the mix but I like that
so I like to have like a really good
balanced hunger crushing combo so I'm
adding some peanut butter and just
because I had these things out also for
breakfast I'll add some hemp hearts as
well
and she goes for chocolate almond milk
but I figure like why not sneak a little
extra protein in so I've got chocolate
soy milk which is typically my
preference anyway
quite
foreign
that's probably good blender up
really good really really really really
really really really really good okay
this is so good like chocolate cherries
how could it be bad I'm gonna go work on
some research and writing and I'll meet
you back here at lunch so it would not
be a day of eating like Jennifer Aniston
if we did not make the famous Jen Ann
salad you know the one that went viral
on Tick Tock a few months back this is
supposed to be the Jennifer Aniston
salad Trend which unfortunately is not
my the salad but really looks incredible
what I feel like my whole life is a Lie
the salad was from the commissary and it
was a Cobb salad that we basically okay
so I'm low-key real excited that bacon
is in and bulgur is out because yeah a
cob sounds way more my style well let's
make a salad we've got iceberg lettuce
which Loki is my favorite
um we have some cherry tomatoes that I
chopped up here Yum Yum Yum we got some
diced chicken
uh some salami
I love that I love a little salami
moment I've got some chickpeas here that
I've just drained and rinsed so good I
love that we have like some plant-based
protein and some animal protein as well
I just cooked a whole pound of bacon and
I'm not mad about it I'm gonna throw a
little bit on top really crispy syrup
I'll give the chewy bits to Poppy poppy
come here girl I got something for you
Christmas
it's a good day all around all right
oh now she's not going to leave my side
sorry babe that's all she got all right
a little bit of that
um let's see okay this one go for it
that was a fail she's getting old
she's getting a little rusty
now Jen didn't mention avocado in her
cob but I have an avocado and I figured
we would use it so
if it's good
baby
look at that
so let's do a half an avocado throw that
in there
I think like all cobs should have
avocado that's like the best hey and Jen
says she has lots of pecorino cheese
and I think that's a nice touch usually
I see cobs with like blue cheese
and I don't love blue cheese so this is
more my style anyway a little Italian
dressing
I feel like we need some carbs I'm just
gonna throw a little Pita on the side
here
does anyone else like cut everything I
just prefer to cut than have to get a
chopping board
so
there we go this looks like an amazing
salad we have tons of protein from the
chicken the chickpeas some bacon in
there some salami healthy fats from the
avocado and the dressing and the cheese
plus some Veggie action and some carbs
and like I said before iceberg lettuce
she just hits different sometimes you
just need the crunch but Abby is it
actually useless nutritionally Iceberg
does have significantly less fiber
micronutrients and antioxidants compared
to darker greens like spinach or kale
and that's because it's about like 96
water and water from food contributes to
our daily fluid needs but like fluids
are important right water is important
and who knows maybe all that iceberg
lettuce help to contribute to Jen's
seemingly Forever Young glowing skin I
don't know just food for thought I swear
this is how all bogus Tick Tock Wellness
Trends start like pretty soon all the
Gen Zeds are going to be swearing off
kale and spinach in favor of ice lettuce
to get that like Jennifer Aniston glow
but I'm getting my salad go get my kids
from school and I'll meet you back here
at snack
all right snack time we love a good
snack so according to People magazine
Jen will usually snack on a hard-boiled
egg with some raw veggies on the side or
an apple with either some almond butter
or like a few nuts again love a good
variety here both great choices and they
both are built-in hunger crushing combos
which we love I'm feeling a little more
of like a sweet snack so I think I'm
gonna go with the Apple let me show you
what I'm gonna do all right Apple I'm
gonna slice it into some rings
and we're going to make like little
peanut butter Apple Donuts that's what I
call them at least guys don't try this
at home
so let's take one of my little fun
cookie cutters
take out the center
hello heart and the one right here
oh no guys don't buy it on Amazon this
is what happens get out of there
five hours later
last one
done that one fixed itself all right
give these out of the way okay I'm
better
I'm gonna dig to the bottom because
there's a lot of oil on top
a little smear
mmm
just like that
a little cement cinnamon cinnamon
oh my God
well that's going to choke me out right
there
it'll be okay yeah it's a cinnamon
challenge Abby's kitchen style all right
and some hem parts
obviously look how fun that is
kind of looks like a bagel but like
sweet
hmm
it's crunchy it's sweet it's sour it's
Savory it's all the things I love
it is finally dinner time and I'm ready
to wrap this day up Jennifer give me
something good and what is Jennifer
Aniston's favorite food I'm gonna say
carbonara
oh that's good that's kind of where I'm
at these days this is legit music to my
ears pasta carbonara is one of my
all-time favorite dishes I will eat this
any day anyway and actually this is a
really great way to use up those egg
yolks that we separated from our egg
whites for breakfast earlier on so we
love a double duty let's make pasta all
right step one I'm going to add some of
our parmigiano cheese to our egg yolks
here a good mountain
not really measuring here just gonna
put in as much as I possibly can until
my arm gets tired okay this is not
traditional in carbonara but one little
hack I love to do with any of my pasta
dishes is to add in some zucchini
noodles which just helps to bump up the
fiber and we get the best of both worlds
we get our pasta and our carbs and we
get some greens and our veg
all right we're just gonna beat these
guys together
not enough sheets
definitely not enough cheese
I'm gonna hit my zucchini with a little
bit of salt just to start to kind of
draw some of the moisture out
well we will saute a little garlic
okay so I just kind of like Pat
the zucchini dry just to get some of the
excess moisture and salt off before I
throw it in the pan there this is
looking good okay turn that off before
it gets too Brown nope
and down
give that a little
and then I'm going to set it aside until
we're ready with our pasta
also not traditional don't come at me
Italians I'm adding a handful of peas
because I like peace
also going to add some leftover chicken
here we got our bacon and
let's get ready to add that pasta I'm
gonna grab a little starchy pasta water
just to bring the sauce together
all right she's ready
add it to our pan a little splash of
cooking water
just to get her moving
and add those egg yolks and cheese
I like a lot of egg yolks so putting the
whole thing in
now we have to toss
a little bit more pasta water possibly
let's see
you gotta kind of move it around quickly
so you don't scramble those eggs
oh but like it looks so good
okay guys she's done she's delicious I'm
gonna finish it with some pepper
let's plate her up and eat it Jen you've
won me over here honey this is my
favorite meal of all time Everybody Take
note we have carbs in our pasta we've
got protein in our chicken a little bit
in the peas and bacon as well plus fats
in all the cheese and the egg yolks and
fiber in the peas and the zucchini like
it looks amazing and I could not be more
excited to dig in
hmm
Perfection okay so as far as celebrity
diets go this one definitely made it
onto my nice list all the meals were
balanced and flavorful we had lots of
variety in the day and I even got to
have pasta which automatically makes it
a really delicious good day and despite
Jen claiming to be Wellness obsessed and
promoting some kind of like pseudo bull
intermittent fasting regimen I would say
her approach to food is generally pretty
well balanced according to a bunch of
media reports Jen tends to focus on the
basics like meditation sleep drinking
enough water and moving her body and
honestly tending to our body's basic
needs is at the core of good health and
let's be real Jennifer's Timeless grace
and beauty is evidence of that but on
that note folks that's all that I have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leaving a comment below on Whose diet
you'd like me to try out next subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]